(xylophone music)
- [Luca] I build models
sometimes with weird materials.
I've always found aviation
to just be really kind
of magical just because airplanes
are engineering marvels.
And I wanted to marry that
with the unconventional
building technique.
- [Announcer] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Geico.
Believe it.
Geico could save you 15%
or more on car insurance.
(xylophone music)
- [Luca] For my day job I
work in IT and management.
but I've just always
been creatively-minded.
I've always been drawn to
those kinds of projects.
I've been making things
since I could figure out
what tape and string were.
I was super young.
I probably drove my parents crazy.
I'm best known for the paper
airplane models that I make.
What I use to build the
models is manila folder,
glue,
an X-ACTO,
and a straight edge, essentially.
It's hard to know exactly how
many folders I've gone through
but I would say it's in the
hundreds for this project,
and there's a lot of scrap left over.
I kept it to a minimal set of materials
just because I like the
challenge of building something
from only one thing and
having to figure out how
to make that serve many purposes.
The model began on a
much less detailed scale.
But I did, over time, realize
that I could start building in more.
Articulating functions,
more details in the interior.
And inside there are
tissues in the bathroom.
There are lights on the seats.
Nothing actually moves in the cabin
but all the detail is there.
I've always just found the triple seven
to be a really elegant,
nicely proportioned plane.
And so it was partly
an issue of aesthetics.
I've always just been a fan
of that particular model.
I studied pictures online.
Some technical drawings.
I actually create my own plans,
and there's just no
guide for how to do that,
so I'm basically learning along the way.
It's simultaneously kind of freeing
and also really frustrating
not to have plans.
I can really take it in any direction.
But you have to be
incredibly inventive about
how you solve problems because
it really hasn't been done.
A lot of people probably
think that my end game
was absolute perfection with the model,
but in fact it was more just
about the process of making it.
It's the thought of the completed product
that inspires me and just being able
to solve such a complex problem.
It's just what I derive a
lot of satisfaction from.